[Music]
welcome sir Samuel Leeds podcast my name
is Amelia and part of the marketing team
and today we're going to be interviewing
him about his journey his story of
finding out the truth about some of your
leads it's awesome to be on the Samuel
lead show I thought it would be good
thing to hear his story first and so I
think we should go all the way back and
I wanted to ask you what was your first
entrepreneurial activity my first
entrepreneurial activity was probably
delivering paper round's when I was like
13 okay yeah and did you have a first
business well I guess it depends how you
define business so when I was at school
I was delivering paper round's I was
washing cars I was cutting people's
lawns I was basically just doing
anything and everything to make a little
bit of money and then I would add a bank
account and I was just I would just save
it like crazy the the bank manager
thought that I was a drug dealer because
everyday walking walking home from
school I just put more money in I would
my dad had a market a market store he
used to sell magic tricks a little
market stand and I used to buy magic
tricks off my dad and then sell them to
my schoolmates for a little bit more and
then keep a little bit I thought I saw
had loads of different I guess they're
not really businesses but ways of making
money my first business was a plastering
business and I told you about this the
other week but I am on my work
experience I went on a building site to
plaster and on my summer holiday I went
to a plastering crash course and learn
how to you know basically plus their a
house but because I was at school I was
taking on jobs I didn't have the time to
do and I would find redundant plasterers
who had no business sense whatsoever and
I would give them the work and then take
a cut so I guess that was probably as
part of my first business because I
guess the definition of a business is
making money when you're not doing the
work so that was my first business when
I was like 15 16 and so definitely even
as a kid
definitely entrepreneur played a lot of
Monopoly most most successful business
people that I know like I'm interviewing
James Caan next week yeah similar thing
he had paper rounds and he played
Monopoly there's those two things if
you're a kid and you play Monopoly
paper arms you're just gonna be a
millionaire okay so did you have you
always been interested in property no
not really no very since a very young
age I got interested in property because
well I read Rich Dad Poor Dad and that
was obviously amazing and that talks
about investments my stepdad was was
doing some had some investments they my
mom and must that they got married when
I was like 12 so my dad was influential
on me as an entrepreneur but then my
stepdad was influential on me on the
property side and I think I just
realized when I was a teenager and when
I wanted to become financially free that
property was the best vehicle to achieve
that and all the people on the Solar
Times Rich List they're all in property
pretty much and I just really liked the
idea of owning houses and even even
since play Monopoly as a kid I wanted to
do that in real life so 17 years old was
when I really went hard on the property
stuff because both you and obviously
your brother Russell Leeds are super
successful he's obviously the CEO of
this company and I was wondering what do
you think it was about your environment
or maybe like your upbringing that have
made you both really successful I think
I don't know exactly what it is because
we me and Russ were the first people in
the family as far back as I can trace in
the family tree that are like really
wired for business and I mean my mom and
dad both were self-employed so my dad
was a gardener and then became a
magician as I said he had a market stall
and stuff and he was reasonably
successful at that he's now got a
different business my mom Mobile
hairdresser so they're self-employed but
I don't know I don't know what it was I
mean we my dad's quite hard on us so he
didn't give us any money in fact no
other of us were given any handouts and
I think that kids that I given handouts
as I see so often people that are really
successful and they desperately want
their kids to be successful and they
give them business loans and they send
them to the best schools and the best we
didn't have that and I think sometimes
have any hard in life and honestly I had
it really hard but we didn't grow it
with money
yeah and there's times of my life where
we had very very little as
and I think I think sometimes that makes
you want even more because you think
actually I don't want I don't want to
live like this forever so but I've no
idea what it is I've no idea why we're
wired that way do you not remember any
like light bulb moment or pivotal moment
when you thought okay entrepreneurship
is for me or properties for me I didn't
like the idea of working a job forever I
didn't like and I think that you know I
always want it and also I have something
just in my belly where I want to leave a
legacy I want to help people I want to
make an impact even from when I was at
school my favorite subject was always
speaker class because I loved getting on
the stage and just sharing and speaking
and entertaining and inspiring for me
part of the reason what drives me to
succeed is because I wanted them be able
to share that and inspire other people
so I almost do it for the stories you
know for me anyway I don't know about
Russell but me and Russell was really
competitive so we also had his own
business and I had my own business and
we were really competitive and that's
why we just decided a couple of years
ago just to join forces and that's when
he joined the business became CEO so how
do you find working with a sibling
amazing watch things the best thing
about it is because you know each other
so well I know Russell inside-out he
knows me I know his floors he knows mine
and we're both pulling in the exact same
direction so even if we disagree on
stuff we both want the same end goal
which is to have a thriving business to
help people so you know I love working
with Russell it's it's the best decision
I ever made in the business so what so
you talk about legacy so what is it that
you want to what would you want to be
remembered for all I want to be
remembered for helping people and for
inspiring people because no one's ever
gonna remember me for having lots of
houses or making lots of money but they
will remember me if I can impact people
and change people's lives so I just
think I just think having a rippling
effect so helping people live a better
life inspiring people to think bigger is
what I want to do remember
so you do that through teaching people
to do with property and property
investing and what is it that kind of
because you were really successful in
property first so what made you then
want to teach was it that desire to help
people I'm kind of I remember when I was
I was actually out in Zambia when I was
like 18 years old and now I remember
being in a village where the the kids
there was a lot of orphan kids the
parents had died and there was this one
boy who was walking 12 kilometers a day
to collect water and I never thinking I
don't even believe that I just can't
believe this someone would have so
little just didn't to me it was just
unthinkable and as a teenager I remember
vowing to God if ever I make it ever
I'll become successful I'm gonna go back
to that village and I'm gonna I'm gonna
in store in still water somehow clean
water into that village for the for the
families and for the kids and I think
part before I even became successful
before I had lots of houses I I almost
always I always taught myself and I made
a promise that I would be generous not
only with my money but also everything
so most rich people hide when you become
rich you don't want to share with other
people how you did that yeah and the
people keep me really close to their
chest and speaking riddles and I just
thought if everyone becomes successful
I'm not gonna be that rich guy who
disappears holds everything close to his
chest you know I'm gonna come and I'm
gonna be generous people I'm gonna be
generous with my time I'm gonna be
generous with my knowledge and I think
as a result of that I just have no
excuse and that's why now a lot of the
work that I do both on the on the
charitable stuff across Africa and the
teaching and it's just because that's
that's me that's me in my core so you've
talked about that when you saw that
you're kind of like oh if I ever become
successful I really want to help
so is it its success something did you
see the success of this business before
it happened like did you think you were
going to be this successful I don't
think I thought I was going to be this
successful when I was 17 18 but I think
why just because it's I mean right now
I'm a lot more successful than I could
have ever envisioned you know just just
financially the size of the business the
amount of people that we impact and help
so it no I don't think everything
it's as much did I see it yes but I
think what happens is every time every
time I take things to a new level
I then envision the next level and just
keep pushing and keep pushing and keep
pushing it most people what happens is I
think when most people get a bit of
success there then relax off
so they'll mana I'm financially free now
that means I can quit my job and I have
to work and then they just ah they cool
off a little bit or their business gets
to a certain size rather thing I'm
comfortable now or this is a good size
but for me I've never done that and I'm
still learning young I'm 28 but I've
been in business now just over a decade
and every time I take things to a new
level every time I'm like wow I don't
stop and pat myself on the back and say
isn't it great
oh this is good I'm comfortable I just
continue pushing it continue pushing it
and I think oh I don't know how long
I'll be like that for but that's what
and when you have momentum on your side
and you continue to put the activity in
the energy in it just snowballs so now I
don't know what's gonna happen next
I've got my next I've got my next couple
years planned so I'm gonna in 2021 I
want to turn over 100 million in one in
this place if you're attending over 100
million a year which is very very
realistic from from where I am now
it's not I'm not I'm not at the moment
we're at about about 12 million a year
turnover so 100 million is the goal but
then when we hit 100 million then maybe
that for me that's almost like the young
thing couple hundred million I can
visualize it it's possible but it's like
okay that's a long step off but when we
hit that no doubt then it'll be 200
million a billion I mean who knows yeah
and that's just finances but there's a
whole host of other stuff that's
incredible what do you think
differentiates you like why do you think
you've been so successful as a trainer
as a trainer because number one I am
actually doing it so you know it's not
I'm not I'm not talking about stuff that
I did five years ago or ten years ago
I'm actually doing it today the way the
way that I teach is very fresh because I
did this yesterday I mean I think that's
one thing I think secondly I think it's
my desire to see people succeed a lot of
people overcomplicate things to make
themself look intelligent
I'm not about that life for me I'm not
trying to make in fact I get accused of
the opposite people say to me somehow
you make it sound too simple and I think
I said that as a compliment
because if I can make something sound
really simple so that a 10 year old can
understand it then actually as a trainer
then that's a good thing and the only
thing also just my absolute passion and
my my determination again to see people
succeed but my passion in it I love
property investing I love making so I
think that comes across and also my
courage as well I'm very unafraid to
look silly so I'll literally pull out my
laptop and find live deals in front of
people at all of my training programs
you'll never come to any of my training
events but I don't get a lap to bow and
find a deal pick up the phone call the
agents and I think that takes a lot of
courage because you're very vulnerable
because you could very easily fail and
sometimes I do fail but again I'm not
I'm not really interested in trying to
look smart or look good to fail
no I'm not scared to fail I just want
people to see how it works in the real
world and I know that failing is
actually part of success and that's part
of the message as well people the reason
people aren't successful is because
they're so scared to fail yeah I think I
need to just know everything up front
everything up front before I take an
action actually the only way you can
learn is by taking one step at a time
and figuring it out as you go along a
little bit so you're gonna fail but
you're gonna fail your way to success
and a mistake is not a bad thing a
mistake is a lesson so I think that's
that's part of the message so if I fail
on stage and I mess up a deal fantastic
it's even better if I succeed fantastic
whatever happens you just kind of draw
the lessons from it yeah and in terms of
failure so what do you think is what's
been the hardest thing for you to master
becoming a successful entrepreneur
what's the one like quality you've
really had to train yourself because
you're not maybe naturally as good at I
don't know what the hardest thing is
there's a lot of hard things I guess
sometimes when it comes to the
organization of stuff I found that
difficult so when I first started with
my properties you know I was getting
lots of tenants I'd lose the ast
contracts I'd forget who'd moved in and
what their paid
wouldn't be I wouldn't have the correct
insurances like the detail stuff and and
sometimes the devil is in the detail my
philosophy is always to look at the big
picture and to focus on the big picture
which generally speaking serves me well
but then I have been you know I've been
caught out by stuff so I think that's
been that's been one problem and then
another problem has been just growing
too big too quick you know and again
that's not necessarily a bad thing but
there's always there's always growing
pains and in every that's my property
business that's my training business
that's my own personal life like when
you go from you know 17 years old
driving around a Ford Ka which worth 500
pounds can't struggling to afford petrol
and then and then within a few years you
dealing with a lot of money yeah it's
it's a massive making money is one thing
and then saving it and managing it is a
whole other lesson so I think that's
something just being you know being
really careful and organized and also
another thing I have to learn and I'm
still learning today is because I don't
really care what people think sometimes
I think I can come across as almost a
bit rude and and in certain instances
just knowing how to talk to people and
and I'm from a were quite a
working-class background so being in
situations where you're dealing with
people that are you know maybe
politicians or like when we bought the
castle and the Free French flew in and
there's these you know really
high-profile people that have lots of
etiquette and I don't know I don't
really know about that stuff so I've had
to learn that so there's definitely been
a lot of learnings and and I'm impulsive
and I'm impatient and learning to wait
for things and that's another issue I
mean jeez there's there's so many but
usually wherever there's a weakness
there's also a strength somewhere it's
just about managing it and being aware
of it and it's because you've not been
patient and kind of sat back it's a
reason for their success yeah one of
them so yeah and I can definitely agree
with what you were saying about the
company growing so fast because the
company's obviously not always look like
this
I know you used to do would you already
see their roles back in the day so I
thought you could maybe tell the story
of when you used to do all that kind of
training and the crash courses and
that kind of thing yeah I mean at the
moment I've got a quote you know you
know you're part of it quite a big
training company we've got marketing
department customer service department
sales department we've got advisors and
coaches finance team logistics
operations team that deal with all the
venues and stuff but there's not one
person here that works in the company
where I haven't done their job at one
point like probably badly even the even
the videography that you do right now
and all that I've done that at one point
so I mean I think the story talking
about is my first crash course when
people I did literally everything
everything I'm not just talking about
the background of booking the venue and
marketing into that I'm talking about
when people arrived there would be me on
reception hey you know I would sign them
in then I would go and usher them to
their seats and if there wasn't enough
chairs I'd have to stack chairs then I'd
go on stage
hey welcome and then I just facilitate
everything when people wanted to buy
books or whatever I then go back and I'd
be taking the payments and fitting out
the forms everything then the event
would finish and then I'd clean up the
room and you know just a personal
everything and then before people even
left the room I'd be there with my phone
taking testimonials and putting together
like a trailer a movie trailer with what
happened following up with everybody
afterwards like it was just me and I
think you've got to be prepared to do
that and anything entrepreneur if you
want to run a business but you're too
proud to stack chairs then you probably
shouldn't be running the business you've
got to be prepared to you to do to do
anything and everything that doesn't
mean you should be the person always
does it because if you're running the
business you've got the stuff to worry
about and you obviously times valuable
I'm not talking about not not valuing
your time but you've got to be humble
enough to do everything business is
there anything that you would change
about you journey probably not I mean
even bad things that have happened
everything happens for a reason even
last year when I broke my leg and it was
it was terrible as a result of that I've
made connections in the hospital when I
was in the heart my leg it was terrible
experience I lost 25 percent of my blood
I was in a hospital in Uganda for 10
days with no food because they don't
feed you
in developing country hospitals and and
it's terrible I may be just lying there
thinking why is this happening I
couldn't fly home because I wasn't fit
to fly terrible experience as a result
of that the mission and the and the
works that was supposed to be doing in
Uganda got delayed and I was just
thinking this is just a terrible
situation God why would you let this
happen you know what wait what are you
thinking but I was just in Uganda last
week and I'm now walking again despite
the doctors in the UK telling me I
wouldn't but the thing is when I was in
the hospital there's a lot of people
that were come in and they didn't have
any money and they were literally being
sent away and they were dying or they'd
been hit by a car and and and now
they're absolutely mangled but they
couldn't afford the operations they
couldn't afford anybody and they just
get sent away and I was thinking man
that's just what I was then is it was
absolutely that was more painful than my
leg I was just it was destroying me and
I said to the house and to the doctors
you know send them in can I sorts can I
do something anyway when I was in Uganda
last week and I just gave a donation to
the hospital and said look if anyone
comes in and don't send them away here's
a fund and I gave some money and must
have take out that that was only two
weeks there was no for a week or two ago
I think just last week
I've just had a message from the doctor
and she said there was someone that came
in three days ago they were hit by car
mangled she sent the pictures and it was
horrible she said we wouldn't normally
send him away but from the fund we've
operated on them and they're going to be
fine
and I just thought that text just came
through a few hours ago from the doctor
and and and it made me quite emotional
but I just thought if I hadn't been
there maybe God didn't want me out in
the villages with the kids and then the
scores maybe he wanted me in the
hospital because there's people but yeah
I just think everything happens for a
reason so when you say would you change
anything even the batter that yes
there's been about things just has been
struggles yes I've messed up yes other
people have let me down yeah but
injuries you have lost money yeah of
course but even in the bad things I just
think everything happens for a reason is
it's about finding the good flipping the
cards
and you know so I've already regrets I'd
probably say no do I wish anything was
different no it is what it is I am where
I am and everything happens for a reason
I believe yeah I love that positive
mindset it's there so on a lighter note
is there anything that like what is your
best moment of your journey so far best
moment of my journey like the one that
would first come to your head that you
only been the happiest or the proudest
of yeah I think it's I think it's just
seeing the successes of my students I
think every single week someone comes
into the offices or into my home and
tells me their story of how they had
their life changed they were financially
free through property as a result of our
training and I filmed that and put that
on YouTube and and that gives me the
biggest kick like like my currency is
seeing people have their lives changed
through the training that we provide so
I think I think that's just the proudest
thing it's not creating the big bank
balance it's not creating big property
portfolio it's not going to be gameplay
it's creating big people and investing
in people so I think that's the thing
that makes me the proudest and all that
the videos be doing so well on YouTube
we did a lot of financial freedom
challenges and things like that and I
just wanted to ask at the end the first
financial freedom challenge that you did
it went viral obviously and I wanted to
know what was your kind of reaction to
that will you expect it to go viral did
you know the content was going to do so
well I think every time I've done a good
video like that I kind of hope it goes
viral it usually doesn't go viral it
usually gets you know it might do well
but that video did particularly well did
I expect it to do super well I think I
hoped it did yeah it was it was exciting
it was amazing but again looking at the
YouTube video if you see the 1.5 million
or however many views it's had its kind
of meaningless how many views is had
what's really meaningful is have people
as a result with that being inspired and
actually taking action and had their
life changed which fortunately there's
so many stories off the back of that
because seeing me start from scratch all
over again it just takes away the
excuses people have because people say
oh it doesn't work in my town well look
I just picked a random town I have a hat
and drove there with an old yellow car
with 450 pounds
with no money and became financially
free in one week like if if that doesn't
inspire you I don't know what well and
then also the teaching threat people
people just modeled what I did just
watched it and then they've gone and
done it and I yeah that's just I think
it's amazing I'm really I'm really proud
of what we did that week and I'm also
really pleased that people have watched
it India and it made me want to do it
again I have I've gone under in America
I'll bet I did it in blackboard where
I'll help someone else become
financially free and it's definitely not
gonna be the last time I'd do more
challenges like that to come so you
always say that the best investment that
you can make is in your self education
and the second best is in property I was
going to ask you what is the third best
investment okay the third last is in
your brand interesting okay explain more
so best is in yourself
ie in educating yourself and growing
yourself and learning second best is in
prophecy because that's gonna that's
going to just give you a passive income
and sit there and grow third besties in
your brand is telling the world what you
do because ultimately money comes from
people and your tenants pay you rent
that's people the property doesn't give
you any money and if people don't know
who you are
then they can't do business with you so
I think if you I'd rather you strip my
bank balance then strip my brand
because if suddenly tomorrow nobody knew
who I was
yeah everybody just that their mind was
wiped from who I am that's good that
that's gonna hinder my business so much
yeah because suddenly I can't do joint
ventures suddenly I can't pick up the
phone and have the best service isn't
the best accountants no one knows who I
am
I've got no kudos I've got no brand I've
got no reputation that's the strongest
thing so I don't invest money into that
yeah I invest money into my brand by
having six full-time videographers like
you you know and and and buy and also
not just money but also time sitting
down and and having the time to put out
a video every single day helping people
teaching people but I'm also raising my
own profile definitely so I think
Brandis is from a business point of view
in a commercial point of view
the third best investment is in your
brand telling the world what you do yeah
that's so interesting because you can
definitely see like the business has
gone it's so incredibly well that all
the YouTube videos yeah but if you do if
you invest in the third thing without
the first thing you've got nothing to
tell the world because if you're telling
the world who you are and you're
branding yourself but you're not
investing in yourself no one wants to
know because it's like well what if you
got to add well if you got to say well
if you got to because if you're
investing in yourself and you're also
investing in telling your story and
getting your brand out there and of
course investing in property then then
you're gonna win yeah that's such good
advice
is there any like what's the best piece
of advice you've been given by someone
else and what is the worst the best
manage not to say what the single best
thing is there's so many like right now
something I just read just very recently
but I thought what a great piece of
advice from James Caan I'm meeting James
Caan next week for an interview and he
said observe the masses and do the
opposite and I think that's really good
advice because if if you jump on the
bandwagon you you've always gonna get
average results because everyone's doing
it
as if you observe what everyone else is
doing even in property you know at the
moment everyone's saying all brexit I'm
gonna wait but when people are scared us
when you should be greedy
so observe what people who didn't do the
opposite and that's a really smart
advice the worst piece of advice I've
had is from people that have just said
stuff like you know hey to earn more
than you need is greed a you know cool
off people that are actually trying to
protect protect me they're telling me to
just you know dog tone it down stop
working so hard yeah don't work so hard
you know just just just just relax you
know that that to me that's terrible
advice so that that's definitely the
worst and the thing is people that say
that kind of thing might mean well you
know oh you don't want to too much money
because because then you'll fall in love
with money actually the people that love
money the most actually usually have not
so when you're starving for a meal and
you've so desperate for say pizza but
then when you have a pizza and you like
mine but then you have a few pieces of
something you call off from your doll
whatever hey do you want something
because you're not hungry anymore and in
the same way people that I know that
have money and my
self you don't need to be so skinflint
so you can relax a little bit I have
some cher son it's all good and you know
myself I do a lot of joint ventures with
people and I like to think I'm quite
generous in the deals that I do because
I'm not like I don't need the money so
people that say you know don't earn lots
of money because you'll be you'll begin
to love it and you'll be greedy I just
think it's it's just them talking from
their lack of experience anyone that
says that I'll ask them look you've been
poor clearly have you ever been rich and
the answer is probably no because I've
been rich and I've been poor and I tell
you which one I prefer every time
beautiful children Ruby and Luke and I
was gonna ask you if you could pass on
one characteristic what would you pass
on ambition ambition yeah gotta want it
the what if you want to be successful
it's never gonna happen unless you
really want it so I think having the
ambition you can you can like everything
else and if you want it really bad and
you're prepared to do whatever it takes
then you're gonna you're gonna get
whatever you want in life so if I could
pass on one thing to my kids it'll be
that that fire and ambition to be
successful to do well definitely and do
you want them to get into property I'd
love them to but they can do whatever
they want
it's aren't even doing a lot of reading
at the minute and I was gonna say what
is one book that you love one book that
you hate and one book that you want to
read okay so I really enjoy reading
people's biographies successful people's
biographies Richard Branson's books
screw it let's do it
he's one of my favorite books so simple
so fresh so fun and inspiring so that
that's I'm gonna probably say that one
there's my favorite book right now look
that I've hated I can't say I can really
remember a book that I've hated that's a
good thing I mean if I read a book I
didn't like yeah I'd probably just put
it down and move on I don't tend to ever
dwell on things I don't like and if I
don't like something I just move on from
it I die so what book if I really not
liked I can't even answer that question
and the question was which book do I
wanna read that I haven't read yet
mmm-hmm oh I've got quite a few at home
on the bookshelf that I haven't read yet
I think more biographies there's people
like
that like Bill Gates and Warren Buffett
and these guys they've they've written
books and this biographies about them
and I've not actually read them yet and
I really should have so because they're
the richest people in the world since
I'm not really is really probably a sin
so there's that what Warren Buffett I
need to read some more warren buffett
bugs in your like everyday life to be
the successful person that you are do
you have any like rituals or rituals so
i pray regularly i I do have time of
choir as well sometimes I go out for
walks quite regularly especially before
a training event if I'm gonna be running
a training event the day before I like
to just know that we have quiet all you
have some time to myself I read quite a
bit is anything you do every day it's
gonna keep your mind sharp or I always
have time for gratitude so every day
before sleep I'm gonna get up I would
make an effort to think about the things
that I'm grateful for that day that's I
think that's a real I guess that's
probably and I don't even see is a
ritual it's not like oh I I haven't do I
need to do it it's just an abit Yule
thing you know when I when I go to bed
and when I get up I just think you know
what am i what am i thankful for that
day and then focus on that and just
honing that even if it's only for like
one minute you know but that's something
that I guess it's part of my everyday
life yeah in terms of that what like
what would keep you up at night likes
anything to do with the business keep
your nothing keeps me up at night I
sleep super well I super well even if
you've got really bad stuff going on and
the stressful things or if we've got an
event coming up which we I need to
prepare for if I'm just about to be
speaking in front of thousands of people
or if we've got you know a court case of
a tenant or I always sleep well at night
because I know that ultimately
ultimately you could strip me from
everything and as long as I still had my
family and my friends and my health it's
all good so I sleep really well nothing
keeps me up yeah you like to put a
little marketing ideas though any phone
and yes probably message you and the
guys yeah and the last thing I was gonna
ask you is do you think you are still
the same man that you were five years
no no what do you think's changed if I
met the old Samuel now yeah what's the
biggest differences well I'm smarter I'm
more experienced I've got more courage
on the back communicator
I'm slimmer if you're the same person of
course I am the same person but well
actually I'm not I think both after a
five-year period probably your skin is
probably no longer you same skin which
means that literally you are a different
you got the same heart and organs maybe
but I don't think that's quite what you
men listen if you even why not watch my
videos if I watch your videos from me a
year ago yeah my attitude is unless I'm
embarrassed how bad the work I hadn't
grown enough so I'll watch your video
from a year ago and I'm like you know I
didn't I didn't explain that very well
the quality on the video wasn't great or
are you know I seem a little but I don't
seem as authentic as I should you know
lose why did you keep saying that or
why'd you keep stiring over your words
or whatever it might be if you're not
embarrassed even this this podcast I
really hope that in a year's time I
watched this podcast and say oh my
goodness I mean what were you saying you
you know you were chatting nonsense you
weren't getting words out properly
you didn't answer it as well as you
could hope because if I look back in the
years time and say wow that was a good
interview then it shows that I've not
grown yeah so now I'm totally different
from almost five years ago yeah and so
on my school friends say somehow you
changed unlike good thank you because if
I hadn't changed since I was at school
you and we were catching the bus
together eating chocolate for
twenty-plus if I haven't changes then I
got serious problems well yeah and in
terms of the company and what is to come
is anything you can give away or your
lips sealed yes I can in terms of in
terms of the company we are going to be
running crash courses in more locations
we're going to be making some of our
training available online as well and
we're just going to be massively up in
the ante on YouTube and putting out more
content helping more people and
definitely not slowing down that's so
exciting
thank you so much for letting me
interview you today
thank you all for watching and if you
have any questions that you would like
Sario to answer and definitely like
leave a review and tell us what you
think about the podcast as well and we
will see you in the next episode
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]